if you own stock at Amazon you are
probably not too happy with President
Trump these days the president's
continued criticism of the online retail
giant has brought stock prices down and
sparked talk of a possible lawsuit
tonight correspondent Doug mackelway
looks at the president's actions and the
public's reaction at least 17 times
President Trump has tweeted his
displeasure at Amazon citing its alleged
abuse of the tax system the Postal
Service and other retailers do you look
at some of these small towns with had a
beautiful Main Street with stores the
stores are all gone Amazon owner Jeff
Bezos has remained silent only when
Trump accused the Washington Post also
owned by Bezos of lobbying for Amazon
did post editor Marty Baron respond
telling the New York Times that Bezos
has quote never suggested the story to
anybody here he's never critiqued a
story he's never suppressed a story a
larger question is the legal and ethical
boundaries of such presidential
private-sector badgering I think the
president's perfectly within his power
ethically the president has an
obligation not to intervene in commerce
because of the ramifications it can have
let's say on the stock market Amazon
lost fifty three billion dollars last
week after reports the president was
obsessed with regulating it conflict of
interest considerations were also raised
today Amazon is a bidder for a new
Pentagon cloud computing contract the
president's not involved in the process
DoD runs a competitive bidding process
radio talk show host Mark Levin a
frequent Trump supporter told his 7
million listeners last night that the
president is wrong on this one I can
imagine where we'd be today if this
mindset had set hold before the
Industrial Revolution what the hell is
this oil stuff I'm in the horse and
buggy business that's not fair putting
people out of business
what are these cars other presidents are
not immune from playing private-sector
favorites as when President Obama
targeted staples but when I hear large
corporations that make billions of
dollars in profits trying to blame our
interest in providing health insurance
as an excuse for cutting back workers
wages shame on them
president Trump's new economic adviser
Larry Kudlow today played down the
president's attacks on Amazon
saying his intent is to quote level the
playing field between online retailers
and land-based retailers with respect to
taxes Chris Doug thank you